okay in our first
story oh my lord i've been warning you
guys
that this would happen any system that
can be corrupted will be corrupted and
i told you that nfts and crypto were
full of
people gaming the system and that you
would be the ones uh who would be the
bag holders you would be the ones being
manipulated well leading nft platform
open c s e a for those of you wanting
wondering just admitted that an employee
was front running
featured drops with a secret ethereum
account before the public had access so
what this means is nfts if you're
unaware non-fungible tokens are like
collecting cards that's what the board
monkey board ape yacht club and topshop
and all this stuff
is about i believe nfts are a really
interesting crypto use case i am not
anti-crypto or anti-nft i am anti-market
manipulation and my anti-people uh
breaking the rules and here we now have
confirmation
of people breaking the rules and not
just a rogue bad actor this isn't the
mafia in
you know russian mafia or rough russian
hacking groups this isn't chinese you
know
black ops nope
literally
this is somebody who worked at openc
so they have featured nfts that are
listed on the front page of the website
uh as you know openc uh devon finzer was
on episode 1255 back in july if you want
to learn more about openc
uh and devin was a great guest and i
think this is a really uh great platform
i think what they're doing is really
interesting and they've recently been
rewarded they've raised over 100 million
and they were recently valued at 1.5
billion in their series b
and there's a lot of issues with nfts so
wednesday morning september 15th openc
published a blog post admitting that one
of their employees was involved in
front-running popular nft drops a drop
means a launch it's just a fancy hipster
way of saying
the release of something so when they
are going to release them they call it a
drop it gets everybody excited it
creates fomo it creates a marketplace
they did not fire the employee on the
spot
nor did they name the employee in
question
instead they said quote we are taking
this very seriously and are conducting
an immediate and thorough review of this
incident so that we have a full
understanding of the facts and
additional steps we need to take they
also implemented two policies regarding
employee conduct openct members may not
buy or sell from collections or creators
while we are featuring or promoting them
i.e on our homepage
openc team members are prohibited from
using confidential information to
purchase or sell any nfts whether
available on the openc platform or not
uh okay
this is insane that they did not have a
policy this is insane that they did not
fire the person and it's insane that
they haven't taken legal action against
the person this is an existential moment
for openc
you need to drop the hammer immediately
and
violently when people do something this
corrupt they absolutely have to take
legal action against this employee they
have to sue the employee yes that sounds
crazy um
so uh according to a report by the block
crypto the employee in question is
allegedly open c's head of product nate
chastain
now i would normally not say the name of
the person
but since it's already out there and
it's everybody's talking about it in the
news it's not like me not saying it
changes anything um the front running
was uncovered uh by numerous twitter
users who traced chastain's
transactional data using a site called
etherscan.io openc is built on ethereum
and utilize a smart contract so all
transactions are recorded and searchable
he purchased cyberpunk number 3501 for
forty thousand dollars in ethereum about
seven months ago according to the block
crypto uh this identifies his main
ethereum wallet which twitter user
xerox and gmi used to trace transactions
to another secret wallet where he was
flipping nfts according to the twitter
user chastain was flipping nfts for 10x
returns in under 10 minutes and sending
the profits back to his original account
okay this is where the immutable
blockchain comes in handy this idiot i
mean not only is what he's doing
criminal unethical immoral
it's also stupid i mean this is one of
the great things about criminals if he's
a
actually a criminal uh you know whoever
did this let's
let's assume he's innocent for now um
whoever would do this is a moral and
this is why criminals get caught so
often because they do something so
stupid why wouldn't he create ten
different accounts
uh use other coins uh wash trade them
etc until the point at which you
couldn't trace them back to him
so
i mean really as far as frauds go uh
this one
was caught but
to me this means that
the department of justice and the sec
now need to do a full investigation
that's right you can't say these things
aren't securities if your own employees
aren't flipping them 10x to make a
profit and do you know what that means
that means you're manipulating your own
customers
for your profit now
i have told you scenarios over and over
again of how people might manipulate the
system
this one i never used because i thought
it's kind of obvious that insiders at a
company could do this but let's pause
for a second
and let's think of another scenario in
which you as somebody who's an
enthusiast base could get screwed
okay i'm starting a crypto project
let's call it uh board bulldogs
you know board bulldog
uh private jet club
the board bulldog private jet club by
jacob
now i make
100 a thousand bulldogs i go to my
friends i say hey besties
create a bunch of ethereum wallets i'm
going to do a random auction
it's not going to be random or i'm going
to do it on this day and i'm going to
announce it 10 minutes after
so i'll announce it 10 minutes late
nobody will notice but you'll be sitting
there with your finger on the trigger
when they launch i want you all to buy
these but more importantly i want you
all to buy them and then buy each
other's and flip them
now
you the sucker sees this trending
everybody's sharing it you see all the
wallets doing this and you think wow
it's going up it's going up there's
volume there's trading i need to jump in
here and grab one of these
so i can flip it and make money and
you buy it and you are what's called in
the business the bag holder so there you
have it folks it's really that easy now
if i describe that and it's such an easy
grip fraud scheme scam for me to come up
with off the top of my head
you can probably come up with 10. go
ahead in the comments if you're watching
the live stream tell me 10 different
ways you would perpetrate a scam well
it's up to the platform openc to make
sure this stuff doesn't happen it's up
to
topshop dapper labs and the players here
but all of this is built on open
you know decentralized technology which
means it's very hard to stop these kind
of things and when they're racing like
this what is the incentive
of open seat to not take
their commission on every one of these
and to not build up their
market cap
now here is something
that uh you know i hate to bring up
i don't want to be a hater or
portrayed as a hater here what if a
company
had this happening
not just with one person but two or
three employees or people who are
partners in the company or investors in
the company
i.e stakeholders so what happens if it's
not just their head of product but one
other person in customer support and
what if it's somebody who's an investor
or an angel uh or a partner company okay
now you got four or five people doing
this and what happens if
uh people inside the company know this
but they don't take action and disclose
it
and then they raise money and
people invest dollars into the company
you've now
on top of doing whatever unethical
behavior we want to categorize this as
right it's some kind of a fraud wire
fraud comes to mind um in this
manipulation but now you just committed
securities fraud
right committed securities fraud and you
go to jail for that
uh and it's not a joke right we have
elizabeth holmes right now on trial she
is uh you know facing serious jail time
for wire fraud and security fraud and
all that kind of good stuff
how much time and money do you spend
integrating a bunch of different
software products together at your
company let me guess way too much time
well odoo is here to help odoo is a
suite of business apps that runs your
entire company on one platform they'll
streamline your workflow by bringing all
of that information together plus odoo's
integrations eliminate repetitive tasks
and data entry if you only need two or
three apps to optimize your workflow
that's all you pay for odoo won't stick
you with the bill for apps you don't use
odu has an app for every business need
they offer 30 main apps that are updated
regularly in over 16 000 apps from their
active open source community you can
keep your books tight with their
financial software and their sales and
crm apps will help provide a clear and
organized view of your business so here
is your call to action your first app is
free forever and right now odoo is
offering a 1 000 credit on your first
implementation pack that's not a joke
that's a thousand dollars just go to
odoo.com twist to check it out that's
odo.com
twist